Asalamu allayikum Dr. Zakumalamu.
I am Hamza from Morocco and one of your
big fans. I always wonder why you don't
target most famous personalities who
have big influence on the world like
singers Justin Bieber edan or actors or
football players Ronaldo Messi Neymar
they have huge followers if one accepts
Islam millions will accept lastly when
will you visit Morocco brother Hamza
from Morocco asked a very good question
he's wondering
Why don't I target celebrities you know
the famous personalities like actors
like football players etc. Brother, if
you can arrange any meeting with any of
the celebrities, I'm welcome. I am
always available. If you can arrange any
meeting with any celebrity who has a
large following, surely I'll take out my
time and do dawa with them. To do dawa
with the celebrities is not easy. If we
get any opportunity, we don't miss it.
We sometimes go out of the way. And
there have been occasions in India when
we had talks which have been a very busy
assort to it that if there is a
celebrity who we have a chance of doing
dawa but we see to it that we don't
break any rules of the sharia we have to
follow our principles we don't do
anything haram to do dawa to them and if
you can do it though there have been
occasions where we have done with many
of the film actors you know had shows
etc with them but I would not like to
waste my time okay if I can I have to
waste 20 40 50 hours and then I'll get
an appointment I better not do it. So if
I'm going to waste 100 hours of mine my
precious time where I can maybe convince
many people or do dava okay if it's
possible little bit more time no problem
once twice thrice four times no problem
but not spend time and then you may not
get results you try for an appointment
you don't get appointment so I don't
really go out of the way if I know there
is someone who can arrange the meeting
I'm available but I will not waste 100
hours and then after 100 nothing happens
you know you try to meet someone you
spend hours so the thing is there that
it's good because even the prophet
always and the Quran says target that of
the so targeting celebrities is good but
I don't want to spend times in which I
will not get results so there are
occasions there where we had
opportunities to speak to celebrities
important people with people of high
profession and he went out of the way to
do dawas. But since you have asked this
question, if you can arrange anyone, I'm
willing I'm always I wouldn't mind
giving double the time also to anyone
who a celebrity and who has a large
following whether they accept or not.
Our job is to do Allah says
your job is to deliver the message
giving in hands of Allah subhanaa tala.
And coming to your last question that
when will I come to Morocco? I've been
to Morocco if I'm not mistaken in 2014.
I visited Morocco. I had been to
Casablanca. I've been to Marrakesh. I've
been to Ra. It's a beautiful country.
Mashallah. Very good scenery. I'd gone
there to attend a conference and I gave
a talk. But that was long back in 2014.
Next when Allah wishes when you know my
requirements are different now. So my
requirements are fulfilled and if there
is time inshallah I wouldn't mind
visiting Morocco again. When will
happen? Allah knows the best. At present
there are many invitations in the
pipeline. We are struggling with time
and we are trying to get slots for the
various invitations that we have
received. Inshallah inshallah if we
receive an invitation from Morocco from
the criteria that I mentioned and if it
takes place I would love to go to
Morocco again. Hope that answers the
question.